we begin this newshour with breaking
news from the conflict in ethiopia where
tplf fighters appear to be on the back
foot in the amhara and afar regions
government troops have recorded several
victories in recent weeks after the
prime minister abi ahmed went to the
front line to lead the army government
troops now saying they've re-taken
control of the strategic towns of deci
and combulture from tigran rebels the
fighters had captured the towns in the
region of amhara in the past two months
let's get martin platt's thoughts on
this story he is a horn of africa
analyst and a senior research fellow at
the university of london he joins us on
skype from there martin platt welcome
back to the newshour how significant is
it that they've retaken these two towns
oh it's very significant i mean the the
tigrans have been pushed a long way back
i mean they have really been pushed back
through towns and villages that they
fought extremely hard to take and they
must have lost many lives in order to
capture them but one thing is important
to realize is that they withdrew they
were not forced out they withdrew with
their troops and much of their equipment
and this means that they possibly can
continue fighting in another location
now i have no idea where that might be
since uh they sweated a lot and lost a
lot of blood to get these towns but
clearly they have now gone does that
mean that they might be planning on some
sort of regrouping over the coming weeks
and months
that's exactly what they're saying
they're saying this was a strategic
withdrawal
rather than being defeated on the
battlefield
now whether that is true or not i'm not
in a position to say and one of the
great problems with this war is that
there are no independent journalists
allowed into tigre to report on what is
going on neither al jazeera nor the bbc
reuters anybody else is allowed to go up
to the front lines so we all have to
rely on outside on reports by the
combatants
there were
areas of speculation i guess martin what
two months ago now up until four weeks
ago people were saying well the tigran
rebels might even have the audacity to
sort of stage a march on the capital on
addis ababa addis ababa now is safe and
secure yeah
at the moment yes that is certainly what
it looks like uh they have withdrawn uh
you know a long way this is you know a
very substantial change in in the
situation and i think the reason is
quite simple uh it it looked as if the
uh ethiopian army was going to be able
to attack them from the flank from the
east and this would have cut their
forces in half and therefore they were
left with really few options but to
withdraw now what they will do from now
i don't know i mean the tigrans are
still a long way in outside of tigre
proper they're in parts of amhara and
the amhara region so what they're going
to do i i don't know and they're not
making their their views known uh i mean
the other thing that really changed
things was the drones which were flown
in via the uae from uh turkey from china
and that seems to have played a major
role in in this victory by the ethiopian
military but the central issues that
have led to this conflict those issues
have not gone away have they
in no way i mean the uh
and both sides are really still fighting
to the end i mean the other thing that's
happened today there's been a a major um
initiative by the international
community i think six seven countries
from australia canada denmark
netherlands united kingdom the united
states have all appealed to the uh
participants of the war to sit down and
negotiate i don't see that happening i
mean everyone has far too much to lose
by uh sitting down negotiating but maybe
i'm wrong maybe there are things going
on uh you have uh former president
ambassador of nigeria is the african
union mediator he said that he's made
quite a lot of progress maybe we'll now
see it on the table but uh i i wouldn't
hold the breath okay we'll leave it
there martin many thanks martin platt
good to talk to you again martin martin
platt here from the university of london